this week on quadriga german spy scandal
Mackel under pressure the Chancellor is
on the spot over German intelligence
service being DS ties to the US National
Security Agency the allegations the NSA
got help from the BND in spying
operations that targeted aviation giant
Airbus the European Commission and the
French government the bmd says it
informed the German government of the
u.s. espionage activities as early as
2008 coming to you from Berlin quad Riga
your host this week is Peter Craven yes
and a very warm welcome indeed for me to
this opening first edition of quadriga
the International talk show coming from
our new studio here in Berlin and what
we're discussing today is what has been
described as Germany's biggest spying
scandal of recent years perhaps even of
recent decades so we're going to be
looking specifically at what just how
dangerous this scandal perhaps is for
the German Chancellor Angela Merkel has
to be addressing that question and other
questions I'm joined here in the studio
by three excellent guests and I'd like
to begin now by introducing them to you
first up Anglo German writer and
journalist Alain Posner who is a regular
commentator for the Berlin based paper
deep-felt
the Germans need to grow up he says of
course Western agencies work together
and of course they spy on each other the
Chancellery pretended that German spies
don't do that sort of thing that was not
only a lie which is par for the course
he says but also a stupid lie which is
inexcusable strong stuff yeah we're also
joined by Eric Kirsch pal born in New
York he's a reporter who has down the
years written for numerous dailies and
magazines in the United States he
currently works for the Reuters news
agency here in Berlin and he says
there's a certain kind of schizophrenia
in Germany on the one hand people want
to be safe from terror attacks and live
in peace on the other hand they're not
happy when intelligence agencies do
their job and making up the trio is
Weiden felt who has worked for a whole
range of germany's most prestigious
business publications as an editor and
author and a prize-winning commentator
for businesses she says it's completely
intolerable to know that your country's
intelligence services are helping your
rivals
to spy on you I'd like to begin with you
Alan Posen a Germany rocked by a major
spy scandal how serious is it
specifically how serious is it for
Chancellor Merkel well we don't really
know how serious it is because we don't
really know anything about this
so-called scandal all we know is that
there has been a cooperation between the
BND the German secret service foreign
secret service and the NSA and we knew
that before we've known this
theoretically for a long time we've
known it specifically since Snowden's
first allegations back in 2013 so we
also know that the NSA has asked the BND
to spy on certain people organizations
and and and companies but we don't know
what about we don't know why and so on
so this could be something really huge
but it's probably something very small
and the whole problem is that we sort of
as the Germans say sort of sticking pins
into the mists because we really don't
know what's behind that mist and the
second part of my question how dangerous
is it for Angela Merkel would you what
do you imagine well you know she she she
she's on the spot because it because a
couple of years ago she said you know
when friends don't spy on one another at
the time she knew that the BND was
spying on all sorts of so-called friends
but on the other hand you know I don't
think most Germans really really care as
long as we've got job security as long
as the economy is growing you know
they're not going to worry about did we
spy didn't we spy didn't I gotta market
of the truth didn't she okay you you're
referring to a comment that Chancellor
Merkel alone is referring to a comment
that Chancellor Merkel made back in 2013
we've got that comment on tape so that
you can hear it now and we've also got a
second comment that you made much more
recently at the beginning of the week
let's listen in on spying among friends
is unacceptable this applies to every
citizen in Germany and as Chancellor I
am responsible for enforcing it on the
other hand intelligence agencies must be
able to work in secret
to ensure the public safety the German
governments will do everything it can to
ensure that intelligence agencies are
able to effectively carry out their
duties allan poe's now you that comment
that first comment that you referred to
just now when made by Angela Merkel you
described that as absolutely inexcusable
and I wonder why you call it inexcusable
when basically what she was saying was
what exactly what the German people want
to hear yes
admittedly politically at the time it
might have seemed like a good idea but
it's you know she might firstly she knew
it was a lie
because her Chancellery is responsible
for this kind of work and secondly
politicians should always assume that
everything's going to come out some time
or another so this lie is also going to
come out so she shouldn't have done it
so to do something where you should have
known that sooner or later it's gonna be
thrown back in her face that's not like
her by the way I mean she's normally
much more careful yeah so that's why I
say it's an inexcusable mistake there
are people who sort of blunder around
like a bull in a china shop he's
normally not like that but this was one
of those moments okay
a big mistake by the Chancellery
Kirschbaum let's bring you in the
influential German news magazine Spiegel
says that the BND scandal puts Angela
Merkel in a tight place is this the
biggest challenge that Angela Merkel has
faced in her what nine years in office
so far it's it's got the potential to be
a problem for her I mean she's done a
good job of controlling the damage and
keeping the damage limited I was sort of
pleasantly surprised by her openness the
other day and saying the NSA is a very
important first and foremost is a very
important partner for the United States
look like the scapegoat and the
troublemaker so there was a bit of a
nuance there of a change away from the
we don't spy on each other kind of a
thing
I think miracle and and her government
realizes how important the Intel
agencies are I think people in France
realized that people in states realize
that in Britain Denmark if you talk to
people in Denmark they would have no
problem with the kind of surveillance
that goes on the Germans because of
their history or would ever have a
special phobia of an intrusive state and
it's understandable but it just gets out
of control sometimes and they do just
wonder what's going on in this country
if the intelligence agencies that
they're spending a lot of money for
aren't gonna be doing the job they're
supposed to be doing mm-hm
I just like to come back to that comment
that we've been talking about and that
we heard from the Chancellor spying on
friends and no-go completely
unacceptable
can you take us back to 2013 and why she
made that comment and sort of fill us in
there because it really is important
she's been me to eat her words a little
bit well the reports all of a sudden
that the NSA was eavesdropping on her
handy on her cellphone had been doing
that for a long time since she had been
an opposition politician and it was one
of those things apparently I mean it's
never really been directly confirmed but
one of those things that just sort of
took a life of its own
they got her cell phone number and I
just kept listening to her and all of a
sudden she was chancellor or maybe not
listening to about want even know who
she was talking to and it was just
information that they were capable of
getting and they just kept kept getting
it and kept to keeping track of it all
this came to light in the wake of Edward
Snowden and the world suddenly saw how
much the NSA was was doing and as an
American if you look at the context of
9/11 a lot of people in the states
wanted the intelligence agencies to do
everything they could to stop terrorism
a lot of the a lot of the terror attacks
that have been thwarted in German like
the Sauerland bombers were probably
thwarted thanks to this aggressive
intelligence gathering and that's
something I think Germans sometimes
forget
well it's interesting isn't it because a
lot of people have been commenting in
the last several days about what Angela
Merkel has said and what she hasn't said
but her main message I think the
implicit message is and this is the area
that you're talking about is that there
half of there has been no major jihadist
attack on German soil and people have to
be happy about that down there because
you know she's doing her job you would
think so I mean just last week there was
a terror attack in Frankfurt that was
stopped the German police arrested
somebody who was applying to attack a
cycling race there I think I have the
feeling Germans don't see the connection
between Intel
and stopping these terror attacks
Germany has been spared these terror
attacks that have hit other countries
like France United States and Denmark
mm-hmm
no fighting felt house Angela Merkel
lied to the German people at the given
wait I mean they you know Alan Posner
has been suggesting that she has been
you know economical with the truth has
she lied to the German people well I
think the key question but not in the
and in the in the film we saw she she
she started with do not spy on friends
went home mobile phone was fired off but
the question is whether she did lie in
the last two or three weeks when she
said there is no other company than a
IDs heiress which has been in the focus
on B and D and Anna's a and I think that
is the we have to discuss a question not
only as a security question about
Germany and terrorism but also as a
political question in Germany we are
halftime to next elections we have two
big parties in a big coalition one of
the partners is not quite happy with
angle america's job because she does it
quite good and they are looking
desperately for something to make her
angry on to make her beast be a
suspicious person for for for the waters
and sigma gap you put the thing on the
scene to say angular michael said she
promised me two times
that is there's only one company
involved in the whole thing
and now he tries to probably he tries to
make her confess there is probably
another one or the three or four and
that's the question of lying or not
lying and i think it is completely
different
it's a completely different question and
discussion from the how secure are
citizens in germany what is the duty of
intelligence what is done in the in the
in the in the in the
in the discussion of security and terror
attacks we have two discussions and what
we do in Germany today and the last two
or three or four days and the next few
weeks is to discuss how will the
partners and the grand coalition deal
with each other's for the next two years
you've been knotting away yes I do think
it's it's perfectly incredible that the
vice-chancellor should go in front of
the press and say the Chancellor told me
there was only two firms involved one of
them as a TAS and one of the other when
as a thinking man he must know that that
it's probably not the case so he's
setting up the Chancellor for a fall now
I don't think that's gonna hurt mrs. Mac
I think it's gonna hurt him because
anyone who really thinks about these
things is gonna say what was this guy
thinking there are hundreds of big big
medium small sized firms in Germany
which are doing relative stuff which is
relevant in the case of sanctions
against Iran sanctions against Russia
and obviously they're gonna you know the
NSA is gonna be looking at them and in
some cases they may have asked B and D
to help them so anyone can think this
you don't have to be an expert you don't
have to be vice-chancellor so to go in
front of the cameras and say oops mrs.
Becker
you said to come on you know um I think
that's but that's just part of this
German schizophrenia I mean he's not
thinking in terms of German interest
he's thinking in terms of party interest
part in whole in there all of the world
this is part of elections and the
preparation prepare to prepare yourself
for elections that is a completely
different from from from the question
for the security question in the USA and
in in in Britain and in France you would
not put your Chancellor the leader of
the government on the spot in a in a
national security issue that's beyond
politics it's everyone agrees that you
don't do that just just the Germans to
think you know he can he can gain easy
points well look so surprising because
Gabrielle has been so supportive of
America the last two years and there's
been no attention at all for two years
so all of a sudden there was a bit of
cage rattling and understandably in a
way his party is in trouble they've been
stuck at 25% in the poll
for two years they're not going anywhere
and there's pressure on him to try to
score some points against America lie
many of you you talk to pollsters in
Germany and look at the polls Merkel
still being so popular at midterm in in
another legislative period is amazing I
mean she's almost untouchable up there
but I think you're right I think it
might have been a known goal for
gabrielle to try to go after America on
this on this scandal can I just pick up
on the point that you've made in the
Ursula's be making we'd be talking about
how incredibly popular Angela Merkel is
and remains in Germany it's very
sustained popularity I just want to ask
the two of you to explain to our viewers
what make makes Angela Merkel so popular
I'm always amazed at how just a voice of
moderation how she really never seems to
anger anybody even the Greece the
eurozone affair she never really seems
to show a temper she never seems to get
upset I mean one of her favorite phrases
is don't try to run your head through
the wall because the wall will usually
win and you see that with Morocco you
see she's just this almost dull almost
this sort of quiet passive way of doing
things but somehow getting things done
and and the Germans seem to love that I
mean journalists might like somebody
like her predecessor Gerhard schröder
who made some nice juicy headlines all
the time but I think German voters like
this dull tranquil voice of doing very
little seeming to do very little not
rocking the boat okay so this is Merkel
the safe pair of hands I'm building up
to something the question once again
what met
what makes Angela Merkel so popular I
think because she doesn't pretend to be
more than she is she's some partition
she's some science she has a very
scientific way of handling things she
just tries and if it doesn't work out
she makes another try and just muddling
through all the things she has to do and
I think it is um Germans seem to be fed
up with people who have visions and have
great plans and just making up gigantic
things - they would do and they will do
I think it is an angular markets way to
just make a good job it is a moderate
politician doesn't promise too much I'd
like to add a third thought if I may and
I would like to suggest that whoa whoa
thing that has made Angela Merkel
attractive for so many German voters is
that she is largely untainted by
corruption and scandal and my question
is now has that has has she lost that
image perhaps in any way in the last
several days amid this crisis I don't
think that she did lose it in the last
two or three days and she won't lose it
in the next weeks or month I think it is
a nice try of Sigma Kappa to bring her
in a position to have to defend herself
but I think she will do it as you're
with deals with I think the jury's still
out on that I mean it could go badly
wrong if all of a sudden the German
public finds out all kinds of deep
secrets but as you mentioned before we
don't really know much about what's
happening right south it would have to
be something really major to come out
which is probably unlikely but I think
the jury is still out whether miracle
could be damaged or tarnished by this
badly probably not but it still early
days we there has been one poll done by
the force her polling institute whatever
respected organization and they came
they they came out with the figure that
62% of the people they they questioned
said that Angela Merkel's credibility
had been damaged in recent days does
that sound important to you yes it does
sound important to me I'm surprised I
have to say but on the other hand look
everyone knows that macro flip-flops I
mean when she when she when she was she
used to be very pro-american and answer
a very free market and she lost an
election basically in 2005 and then she
you know and then she went and became a
middle-of-the-road more or less almost
social democratic politician was where
she is now she's a very transatlantic
cyst now she's more a German national
politician do you see very much for
European integration now she has a more
intergovernmental approach so everyone
know is that Merkel
isn't what she seems and and and and
keeps her cards close to her chest and
and you don't know what she's gonna do
so you know what does what's credibility
in this case I mean she delivers that's
the point
okay well certainly the consensus here
in Germany at this point in time among
the media is the Chancellor
and enter government or under some
considerable pressure we need to look a
little bit more closely at where it's
coming from where where the core of this
the crux of this story is and to do so
let's go down to Bavaria this is one of
the most powerful listening posts in
Europe the bad idling station surveyance
base the facility is gigantic 13
communications satellites and 180
transmission routes are tracked here
originally run by the US Army and the
National Security Agency it was turned
over to Germany's BND intelligence
service in 2004 in return the Germans
agreed to pass on data to the NSA using
search terms known as selectors the
spies contract names telephone numbers
or email addresses to monitor their
targets it's still not clear exactly how
close the cooperation between the two
intelligence agencies has been it seems
that the US did not entirely give up its
presence in bad idling station
well let me just remind you that you're
watching quadriga here on Deutsche Welle
coming to you from our new studio here
in the heart of Berlin we're discussing
angle of miracle under pressure in the
midst of a spying scandal here in
Germany and Eric Kirschbaum in that
report what we see is the Americans
turning over what was a prized piece of
their own property which was a listening
station that had been very important in
the Cold War they turn it over to the
Germans the Germans the German spying
establishment and they give them a list
of search criteria names phone numbers
IP addresses and the Germans use those
to to collect information for me that
sounds like in the first instance
cooperation rather than something
scandalous exactly I mean my American
ears aren't all that upset by that
either and the way I understand by
labelling a lot of the listening and
eavesdropping goes towards the Middle
East not necessarily against German
citizens so I wonder why Germans
sometimes get so worked up about things
like that because the BND
the German intelligence isn't is not
allowed to spy on German addresses and
the agreement between the US and Germany
has been to sort out all the German
addresses all German phone numbers and
do do not spy on them and probably it
has been has happened we don't know it
if it has happened up but if it has
happened that is not legal why does the
BND have its hands tied behind its back
then because under the BND is not
allowed without the agreement of of the
american of the american intelligence to
just publish the selector lists or to
just give a hint what are the things
they were looking for what are the key
the key things the selector lists how
did they just choose what to to what
what to to collect and what what but
there's a parliamentary control for all
these all these agencies and the BND
you would think would be controlled by
the Parliament committees yes but I
think we do have the question whether
this controls are a factor whether they
okay
and whether they were just up-to-date to
the new corporations between the US and
and Germany what what do we know about
the ominous list yeah I've got a quote
from the zuytdorp chat site and the the
the one of germany's most prestigious
newspapers yeah a munich-based daily
it's reporting that the search lists
included and I'm quoting now thousands
of email accounts from European
politicians and European institutions so
you have to imagine that the damage that
was done has been done is considerable
and were not just targeting targets in
the Middle East as you put it today as
well it was the big Sony film scandal in
last year as well where the Sony film
executives were surprised their emails
were being were being tapped by somebody
so yeah it's gone out of control and a
lot of people in America think it's gone
too far the US Senate just made some
changes this week to put some controls
on it but it's interesting Frances going
the other direction for more controls
the United States is scaling back spies
spy I mean that's what they're there to
do and if they break the law sometimes
that's part of the business that's part
of the business of spying since the
beginning of time hello an EU politician
is not just an EU politician he or she
could be a member of a left-wing radical
party could be a member of a very
right-wing party like shall we say
marine depends outfit or what have you I
mean there's lots of reasons you might
want to spy on members of European
Parliament for instance again also the
there's a whole question of sanctions
regimes which you have in place against
Iran and against Russia at the moment we
all agree that's better than war but you
have that includes you have to see are
these sanctions gonna work so if you
have for instance the Greeks just say
wondering should they break the
sanctions regime you want to spy on the
Greek people in in in in Europe to find
out what are they really thinking are
they just bluffing are they really gonna
break ranks so there's all sorts of
reasons perfectly legitimate reasons
which have to do with political aims
which have been agreed by voted elected
political illegitimate reasons although
the selection of perfectly legitimate
targets includes the
presidential palace well quite frankly I
don't know what they wanted to get there
but look there was also I mean I don't
know when this was went but there was
the case of whether the French would
deliver an aircraft carrier to Russia
you might really want to know is mr.
Holland going to do that go through with
that which he did more isn't he
and so yes it is a legitimate is it
legitimate a man of mr. Holland is at
all conscious of his place in the world
then he'll have a safe room to discuss
things like that hmm
I mean it was a little bit in my
question was a little bit cheeky I know
but the reason why I asked it is because
the French have been complaining they're
demanding clarification you'd expect
them to be angry to be outraged by this
but they're not quite are there they're
sort of going through the motions what's
the reason for that I think in the wake
of the terror attacks in France and in
January the the sentiment in France has
changed as well it's it's there 9/11
Britain had its terror attacks a while
ago as well and there was a whole change
in the outlook and security in Britain
as well Germany has been spared a major
terror track I mean I think the last big
of terror attack was in in northern
Africa about ten years ago then Germans
were killed Germans they're just in a
very fortunate position that they
haven't really been but touched by
terror the way other countries around
here have picture will change if there
had been a terror attack in Germany oh I
don't think I I don't think so that the
opinions of on on on spying on
intelligence would change so much
because um what we are talking about now
is did they do
probably legitimate things but preserve
legal or not and if it is the business
of intelligence services to break the
laws they shouldn't be trapped and I
think this is the the problem we have
now it is probably that we just have a
situation - no no in a few days that the
BND has broken German leg Allah if the
BND spied within German
on German citizens it's beyond the remit
and that is definitely a cause for
concern and for consequences but we
don't know that yet simply saying that
there were Germans firms were spied upon
we're talking about Airbus which is a
German it's a European consortium they
could aspire on them and to lose or
anywhere so so there's no law to say you
can't spy and wherever a German firm is
doing business for instance I think if
if if it turns out that the BND did
break German law there have to be
consequences and that is all the thing
we are discussing now we don't discuss
some the opinion of abroad a German
public on on the intelligence services
in case there is or there is not a
terror attack I think everybody in in
German is quite grateful for the
cooperation of intelligence services in
order to protect them for from
islamistic attacks or whatever either
day miracle kept using this word balance
she's the one that needs to find the
right balance between civil liberties
and security and and it's a moving
target it's never really a perfect
target no okay you were mentioning the
the whole of the whole chapter of the
story about industrial espionage we've
we've heard about it a little bit
already one of the targets of the
surveillance the activities that were
going on in Bavaria was EAD s what has
now become Airbus let's here just a
little bit more about that story and
those comments that we've been hearing
about from the German economy minister
in response
suspicions are growing that Airbus
manufacturer EAD s and the defense
corporations eurocopter subsidiary were
targets of the spying operations were
there other cases of industrial
espionage as well German economics
Minister and Vice Chancellor Sigma
Gabriel has placed Chancellor Merkel in
the spotlight when the suspicions first
emerged I asked the Chancellor twice if
there was any indication of economic
espionage beyond the known case of EAD s
both times the answer was none Gabrielle
has bluntly put the responsibility on
the Chancellor some commentators see
that as an attempt to expose Mackel as a
liar they say it could be a sign of
coming disharmony in Germany's governing
grand coalition listen if I can party
you're you're a business journalist
primarily so I'd like to ask you what
just explain for us what the
significance is why it's so sensitive if
Airbus is spied on both strategically
and and and emotionally for the
Europeans I'd have to say yeah I think
the main thing is whether the BND has
helped the NSA to spy on our air
Brazoria ideas but if you look at the
world plane production and the defense
industry there are two big competitors
just Airbus IDs and Boeing and if you
have reason to be suspicious that
probably and as a with the help of P and
D had spied on EAD s and a bruisin
probably in order to help Boeing or to
give some information through that would
be really concerning four four four year
the SM they filed for an investigation
last week Sony they are concerned how
serious is that for that I mean you know
it again is this a token gesture or is
this a real threat to the German we
don't know anything about that but we
know that Sigma gavrio just mentioned
iAds
and that he put it on the scene and just
made Angela Merkel to react on that he
said I asked her two times she said two
times
no there is no other company and we have
now two things to discuss whether is
there's a second company and is it what
has happened to e ideas actually he was
he was even more explicit he said I
asked the Chancellor if there was any
other case of economic espionage as part
from yeah I already know that there is
another one so which is which is not the
case he doesn't know that it was
economic espionage she only knows that
the company was spied on might have been
for quite legitimate reasons what do you
suspect
do you suspect that there is a long list
of you know surveillance of industrial
and economic targets yes I do because
with regards to Iran and its nuclear
program for instance from a tunnel
building equipment which the Germans are
very expert in and have delivered
already two cranes construction
equipment two different pieces which can
be used of equipment we can be used in
centrifuges and so on Germany has lots
of links and by the way the Iranians
have a lot of Airbus aircraft which are
falling apart due to sanctions and there
might be very good reason for Airbus to
want to deliver an engine or two or
something via Dubai to Iran so no I
don't know but I but you know not
neither does mr. Gabriel but he's
talking about economic espionage as if
it were a fact and that I think is
irresponsible quite frankly eriko spam
why are the Americans in the first place
why is the NSA engaging in this
cooperation with the German spying
agency they could sure that they could
do their intelligence gathering from
Montana or from the Yorkshire Moors you
know they the more the better I mean
there's a two-way street the BND profits
from the NSA and vice-versa and you know
you mentioned Airbus and Boeing they
don't just make commercial planes they
also make a lot of defence it's a big
defense industry there as well so
there's an interest in knowing what the
other sides are doing with the defence
research and planning my reference to
the Yorkshire Moors was quite deliberate
because obviously if the Americans do
this kind of engage in this kind of
cooperation with the British then few
people are likely to complain here in
Germany there are special sensible
you referred to them earlier but we've
had two dictatorships here on German
soil and living memory that makes people
very sensitive about this kind of thing
do you understand that yeah I live in
Germany in Germany for a long time so I
understand right it all my stories and
my German language colleagues always get
upset when I make links to the Stasi and
the Nazi they don't they don't think
there's a link but I think outsiders
looking at Germany need that reference
point that context understand why
Germans do you get upset about this I
think when Obama came to Berlin a few
years ago I think he was overwhelmed at
how upset the Germans were about about
these things but you mentioned earlier
that German probably aren't that upset
about it most of the time and when I
talk to the floors upholster this week
mantra gulnur he said most of the time
only 1% of the Germans really care about
this this NSA stuff in the one week
where a Miracle's cellphone was that
came out it jumped up to 44% so that one
week when very tangible thing Merkel's
cell phone was being was being bugged
that's when everybody cared it was the
one moment where where this really
jumped out of the chattering class and
into the into the wider public when when
something tangible like Merkel's cell
phone being tapped is a chattering class
scandal well I think it is it is about
things
it is about cell phones and everything
which is quite abstractly just baths
everybody doesn't in it's not not not
small enough to just be to talk about it
to to have to find a point to make up
your mind so I think it has to be a cell
phone or a IDs everything which is in
between is too it's too complicated to
talk about that
yeah but the Germans are really you know
let's talk about our we're so worried
about dictatorships and so on we have
IDs everyone has to carry their ID on
them everyone has to register with your
thirties where they live
British people wouldn't but wouldn't
dream of letting the state know all this
nor would Americans when I go to a hotel
I have to sign and show my show my ID I
don't have to in Britain don't have to
in the United States
about freedom here we talk about
identity on a security unknown you your
serenity to to have your own date data
for your own and to decide by yourself
you know do you know what the hotel does
with the data you give them they keep it
for weeks and weeks and weeks you don't
know what they're gonna do with that I
get letters all the time that my private
address from from people who've got hold
of my private address from some
Authority or other they're sold on the
open market
so come on that doesn't make it good
because you can explain it so you sound
a little bit like an apologist I mean
with no no I'm just saying the Germans
freaking lands for concerns because I
think many Germans when they see what
the NSA is getting up to many Germans
say the NSA is out of control they see
what are the related agencies are doing
they see what the five eyes nations are
doing they see Google they see Facebook
they see Twitter and they see Amazon and
they worry I mean the one of one of the
slogans that's used in German is that
this is digital colonialism you don't
see anyone you know giving up their
Facebook site because they're worried
you don't see anyone not using Google
Google has a 90% penetration of the
German search market only 65% in the
United States why did the Germans use it
if they're so scared of it that's what
I'm talking about schizophrenia I'm
always amazed by that as well I mean
Germans get so worried about this and
that they don't want to know anything
they don't want to but then they put all
our information on Facebook or Google or
whatever it's it's not an excuse to say
well everybody is using it so it seems
to be not important to German citizens I
think if you do make mistakes or if you
just learn how to handle things it's
it's not an not an not you you you you
you always will make mistakes and you
and you always will be some kind of not
too careful with your data but that is
not an excuse but not an excuse for just
having intelligence agencies just
grabbing all data they can can can get
yeah but what I'm saying is we have
authorities and organizations here in
Germany gathering data about us which we
wouldn't do in any other
freedom-loving country our own into
interior security operators for instance
and the police and so on and so on but
when it's the Americans that
the point there is an inherent
anti-americanism when it's anything
oh it's just all about the BND and the
christian whether the BND has whether
they work for the Americans that I have
the feeling you're right I'm leaving
some people if the if the BND we're
working for the Russians right now it
would be okay it is not an Americanism
what we're talking about
everybody nearly everybody it's really
grateful for the corporation to protect
European citizens from attacks from
islamistic groups from whoever name it
but but there is one limit and the limit
is the the law with which is German law
which is furn law which is European law
that is the limit
when we talk about the failings of
Angela Merkel and this scandal in the
everything since 2013 and they and the
the Snowden revelations it has been
argued that there was a bit of a blunder
on Angela Merkel's part and I'd like to
quote the build site of the the the
large circulation newspaper here in
Germany it said that Angela Merkel
failed to explain what Secret Service's
do that they protect the interests of
their own state and they sometimes have
to ignore the laws of other countries
should protect the interest yeah is this
the bottom line that the Germans have to
be educated to accept that the bad
things happen where intelligence
agencies are at work that these are dark
and murky places I think so and I think
that's why I hear comments the other day
and surprised me because she was
sounding very Pro NSA all of a sudden
and that's something not something I
think she would have said two years ago
and my ears perked right up I thought
that was definitely news mmm I think it
was a change
mmm is one of the things we're seeing
here that Germany is still completely
dependent or in very very large measure
it at this point in Germany's post-war
history Germany is still very dependent
on the United States of America in very
many fields including information
gathering intelligence gathering because
it does not have its own full and
independent operational capacities well
I don't know I mean
obviously we're depending on the United
States in in all aspects of security and
we will continue to be Europe as a whole
world continue to be Britain will be so
and that's fine by I think most Germans
era agree with you at the same time
there's this resentment okay so it's a
schizophrenic idea on the one hand we
don't want to do what we would have to
do to be totally independent which spend
a whole lot of money and so on but on
the other hand we sort of resent
American domineering as we see it so
there's that schizophrenia is there mmm
there's been a change in the United
States as well I mean I think Germans
might not have picked up on it but
people in America are afraid as well of
the NSA getting out of control and I
think in the last few years there's been
a push back against that and I think I
wish Germans would be a little more
aware the United States has taken steps
to rein in the NSA and and and put some
safeguard people's privacy as well give
me a quick idea does the does the the
BND
need to be reined in when you use that
phrase no I don't think so I think I
sleep better at night knowing the BND is
out there to paraphrase Lyndon Johnson
and I think they're doing a good job and
I hope they keep a Germany a safe place
to be a very sanguine take that does the
BND need to be reined in I'm so good I'm
gonna press the question because that
you know in many ways that's what where
the discussion has gone here in Germany
in the last couple of days but I think
that there has to be better control even
in the Parliament as I in the end with
from from from the Chancellor hmm it has
to be better controlled when you see the
people who are in the in the Commission
of Parliament who are supposed to
control the BND when you see who's
couldn't in control of the Chancellery
these are mostly second-rate people and
they shouldn't be this before straight
people and they should have first-rate
apparatus to deal with it it's like with
the with the Commission for foreign
policy in the in the in the Parliament
no one wants to go in there because you
don't make a career you make a career in
Germany by being an expert on on
pensions or whatever yeah so so we need
people to take this seriously and we
need the right people to be in the
parliamentary commission to be in the
Chancery control of the of the BND and
we need them to have the right apparatus
so I'm
yeah I'm all in favor of control you
know trust but verify with your own
topic today what we have been discussing
the core of our discussion has been
angular Merkel under pressure how
dangerous is this is this affair going
to prove for her or not what so what
would you say Eric is it
Teflon Merkel gonna survive this is she
gonna weather the storm probably I mean
you mentioned the word muddle before and
I think she will be modeling through
this and there won't be any big R
elevations probably and I think in a
month time nobody will really remember
even this at all it'll just be a blip on
the horizon don't be passed but they
won't forget Gabrielle did stand up to
her and kicked her shins a bit a very
quick word from each of you I mean I
think this is a very serious crisis for
the government well I think it is a
serious crisis because what could become
a serious crisis because the best
partner sigma Gabriella and Angela
Merkel are in a conflict here one word
very short
I think Albert's gonna regret it there's
never been a man stood up tomorrow who's
lived to see another day she'll get her
own back he might be the biggest
casualty you've been watching quad Riga
from our new studios here in the heart
of Berlin we'd be discussing German spy
scandal of Angela Merkel under pressure
I hope we've given you plenty of food
for thought if we have come back next
week and do get in touch via Facebook
Twitter or by mail
for now though that's your lot Oh
bye-bye and trust from me